hello everyone and welcome to a most
interesting game from well it's another
game from the HS 24 banter blitz cup
Bulgarian Grandmaster even chokerino vs.
Magnus Carlsen Chaplin have eliminated
even charge from the competition whereas
the Magnus eliminated the Ralph mom and
off in the previous round and it's one
of the games that I thought was was
worth showing a lot of them were
interesting but this one really really
features a very special move and the the
match started with Chaplin of winning
the first game it was it was a nice
Queen sacrifice that Magnus overlooked
and then here i checkmated
but then Magnus won three in a row and
like Magnus said he didn't play all that
well but the the results you know still
went in his favor as chipper you know
didn't take advantage of all the
positions he got so he said that
probably cheaper you know wasn't feeling
all that great about that but here
cioppino really goes all out and it's
really really a wonderful game so
without further ado let's check it out
chap arena opens with b4 and like the
corner the top left corner shows if you
happen to run into a team or a job of do
wish him a happy birthday as today is
his birthday so the four Knight to f6
we have Knight to f3 and not going for
any any c4 idea so Magnus can choose an
opening so here Magnus goes for b6
preparing a Queen's Indian set up he's
preparing to fianchetto the light square
bishop we have g3 jeopardy knows does
the same there should be seven and now
c4 we have g6 by Magnus as white didn't
really force any matters in the opening
Magnus takes his time to think ghetto
but of his bishops Bush up to g2 and now
Bishop to g7 we have Knight to c3 and
now as it's available and Magnus grabs
the d4 square for his Knight and maybe
has ideas for off trading some pieces we
have Queen to c2 putting now pressure on
the night here and Knight captures on c3
will be captured and now there are a few
moves that are known in this position
like d6 f5 Castle seasonal move but the
move Magnus place is a new move so
already as a move aid we have a
completely new game so what do you do
here
we have efore of course grabbing more
space in the center and now Knight to a5
magnus goes for the double C pawn with
his Knight and frees up the LightSquared
Bishop Knight study - defending also
opening up this light for bishops
diagonal and here Magnus castles and h4
a chopper in Oh says I will not Castle I
want to play h5 I wanna bust open the
position and start an attack against
Constance King
Carlson replies a with with a strike in
the center which is a very always I will
mention this is a very principled idea
when your opponent attacks and the King
said you want to strike in the center so
c5 and of course it's principals from
White's that keep the center closed so
d5 and now Bishop the a sex again Magnus
goes for D for the weak c4 pawn and
queen d3 chaplain of defends it and now
again Magnus doesn't allow a chopper
enough to continue the attack he goes
east 6 and now trading here for example
that doesn't do anything for white as a
queen trade would be favorable for black
black would get a nice look on the open
D file and you would still have the weak
c4 pawn so not something you can do so
here
d6 keeps at the center closed and yes
it's again a principled idea but it will
be a tough pawn to hold on to as Magnus
himself said in the industry we have
worked the c8 now his idea is he wants
to play rook the c6 he wants to play e5
Queen f6 and then the rook and Queen
will cooperate to gobble up the d6 pawn
so f4 chaplain of needs to create an
attack on the king said before this
happens with E 5 and now h5 now the
attack starts we have worked the c6
magnus still continues with his plan
captures and g6 captures and now even f5
and here Magnus goes for Queen to f6
continues with its plan but maybe it's a
bit too soon yes now you're threatening
to capture here but there is a move that
Magnus missed so feel free to pause the
video and try to find this this very
nice move that Magnus missed while I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on supporting the only
move that gives white advantage and it
is in fact
Perrine of plate and for those who just
want to enjoy the show it's g4 really a
nice idea opening up the path here for
the Queen to reach h3 and from h3 to h7
and for those of you who maybe saw it in
the thumbnail you probably had it easier
finding that the g4 move
but then again congratulations for
paying attention and here you have to do
something about the Queen h3 the queen
h7 will be checkmate so Magnus after
dwelling on it for I think maybe even
around maybe 40 seconds now I don't
think it was a minute maybe around 40
seconds I plays rook to e8 it simply
gives his Hindi f8 square and it's not
gonna be a problem since check check you
don't have any other checks since the
bishop nicely covers the dark squares so
Queen to h3 just the same and now G
captures on f5 by Magnus and here here
is the moment where chopper II know I'm
kinda didn't go in the best possible way
here it's important to give the Knights
the e4 square so you can either capture
here and give the Knight d4 square this
way or it's possible to even play g5 to
open more lines in front of the in front
of the black king and after captures and
now you capture an f5 and giving your
Knight d4 squared this way plus you're
also attacking the rook here on c6 so
after E for you would see Knight
captures on e4 Queen to f6 of course the
knight is pinned so you cannot capture
but after king f2 it's gonna be really
hard for Magnus to defend as the Queen
is under attack you have to either give
up the exchange here or move the Queen
and then f6 is just game over for Magnus
but it's a blitz game so of course you
cannot see everything but it's important
to give this Knight to e4 square
chapatti not however played G captures
and okay maybe if you can develop your
dark square Bishop maybe if you can
castle here maybe if you can get the
other Brooke to g1 maybe good things
will happen however that's a lot of
maybes so Queen captures and descends by
Magnus and now as the c4 point is still
hanging first Bishop to f1 by chip arena
Magnus gets the King away King to f8 and
now comes Queen to h7 so here again feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the best move for Magnus while I give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting
either of the two moves that I'm gonna
mention but if you found the move magnet
plate that that is the absolute best
move so for those of you who just want
to enjoy a show
Bishop to h6 is fine it prevents this
well it disconnects the Queen and the
rook but even better is queen cat Queen
to h6 which magnets plate and he really
played it instantly just in a second so
it was really really awesome stuff
of course now you're just threatening to
trade Queens and if you look at the
position of Queen trade it goes a long
way for black and even though it's a
temporary Queen sacrifice it's not a
problem
socha preen of plate captures here
although you could just wait maybe
Knight to f3 maybe improve your position
a bit but it's still it's still not
gonna be much better so chapati enough
captured rook captures on h6 we have
rook captures and h6 Queen captures
Bishop captures and it was in this
position that even Shapiro resigned the
game as well it does seem like there's
something to do but there really isn't a
lot because your c4 point is still weak
well both of these phones are weak and
for example if you try something like
Knight of three to try and activate your
pieces a black and even wait Bishop
captures an c1 let's say rook captures
and c1 and now even f6 this is the c4
pawn is still oh sorry the c4 pawn is
still a weakness and now after you
defend it nice the d2 now what are you
gonna play here
the knight and Bishop are stuck guarding
the c4 pawn the rook has no ways of
entering the game and black will simply
play King f7r okay trade rook h2 let's
say and bring the rock into the game
this way and blacks position will be
simply so much better and with good
Magnus being better on time it's just
gonna be a very slow death for chip
arena so that's that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it and it was it was
really a beautiful move this Queen to h6
so I do hope you enjoyed that but yeah
after this trade that supremely decided
it was time to call it quits the match
ended the 10 games they played ended
with eight and a half one and a half so
only one game was lost by Magnus that
was the first games we mentioned and one
of the game was drawn or eight other
games to Magnus one so really really a
good performance by magna
who advances into the higher parts of
the of the banter blitz cup and I also
wanted to mention something about the
candidates tournament here is a tweet by
by just twenty four quoting basically
magnets from this stream something about
a candidate's tournament this magnet
says I think in general its favorable
favorable to dink that Maxine place
instead of her job of although the job
of is solid I think Fabiano is better
than ding at beating the slightly lower
rated players and I think in order for
dink to win he probably has to beat
Fabiano this is a Magnus's opinion about
the the events that happened with a job
of well leaving / being kicked out of
the candidates tournament due to the
coronavirus and Maxine taking his place
and also I heard news that Ivanka will
not be using any seconds in the
candidates tournament as he doesn't want
them to also go go through a quarantine
so now do you agree with Magnus what are
some of your thoughts on that I would
also like to enjoy reading about that in
the comments chef that's pretty much it
I do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Kody Holden
Morten restore Jonathan Owen John Austin
and begum impacts SRL after a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
and think all for watching and I will
see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Paul
Morphy saga continues to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day